donc christian été sifflé le 27 mars
2002 au stade de france pendant france
ecosse alors il avait déjà été sifflé
pendant la présentation des équipes
ensuite quand il est entré sur le stade
pour remplacer candela et à chaque fois
qu'il a touché le ballon un peu comme
dugarry qui était beaucoup sifflé aussi
alors évidemment on peut dire que c'est
improductif parce qu'il va pas l'aider à
gagner c'est clair en plus c'est
dégueulasse et puis ça va pas donner
envie à thierry henry de revenir jouer
en france parce que il craint ça alors
tout le monde est très énervé là dessus
lui prend c'est avec une certaine
douceur
il dit je suis déçu d'être sifflé
surtout parce que l'on touche à l'équipe
de france
est-ce qu'il est plus blessé que ça ou
est ce qu'il le prend vraiment comme ça
va
bien sûr qu'elle est blessée ça ça c'est
normal mais il montre pas trop et puis
ensuite par rapport à les autres joueurs
il veut pas montrer à tout le monde que
c'est grave ça fait très mal sur tout
cas
s'il a fait peut-être quelque chose très
très mauvaise sur le terrain je sais pas
où on rentre ou en touchant le ballon ça
mais ça c'est énorme
alors on a cherché des explications à
ces sifflets on a pensé que c'était
peut-être à cause de ses prises de
position sur la reprise des essais
nucléaires en polynésie en 95
bah si c'est ça
les gens sont peut-être jaloux parce
qu'il a une super voix là
non parce que par peut-être que si tout
va bien des gens
je cherchais quelque chose je sais pas
quelle est la raison de sa votre avis
les kanaks
voilà ou si c'est parce que il joue en
grèce et puis on voit pas trop les
matches on va pas trop les matches qui
sont qui se joue en grèce alors les gens
peut-être se demande pourquoi pourquoi
il essaie l'exploit je sais pas vraiment
on cherche et paix je sais pas si ces
raisons là sont suffisants pour placer
quelqu'un comme ça
alors ce qu'il faut rappeler quand même
c'est que les ancêtres de christian
karembeu ont été amenés de nouvelle
calédonie à l'époque coloniale pour être
exposées dans des zoos humains
le dimanche les gens allaient voir les
kanaks derrière les grilles à l'époque
de l'exposition coloniale dans les
années par les années 30 c'est un petit
peu le love story d' d'avant guerre
et quand on sait ça c'est encore plus
dur de le voir siffler c'est un symbole
magnifique
c'est un grand joueur et il le fait que
toutes les provenances soient rassemblés
sous le même maillot tricolore c'est une
merveille à défendre et c'est un symbole
qui a eu beaucoup d'importance en 98
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas pour rien que le
pen a attaqué ce symbole parce que c'est
un symbole qui le gêne donc on est avec
lui voilà
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu